Forests have always been a coveted resource
for humans. They also tend to be quite dark
and spooky. Maybe that’s why there’s a
long history of humans inventing monsters
whose real purpose is protecting
the forests. In parts of Russia,
the shapeshifting Leshy guards the forest against
ill-intentioned hunters and harvesters. A Leshy
helps you out of a tight spot—but only if
you’ve given an appropriate sacrifice and
avoided disturbing the flora and fauna. And if you
don’t, they’ll trick you into harming yourself.
Then there’s the poisonous Umdhlebi
[oom-LEH-bee] Tree, or dead-man’s tree,
a toxic plant in South Africa. According to the
Zulu people’s legend, the temperamental tree takes
nutrients from the poisoned corpses littering the
soil around it. The tree’s valuable fruit can be
collected only after it has already fallen to the
ground—a handy device for sustainable harvesting.
And let’s not forget the Mapinguari. A giant
Amazonian monster, this creature will literally
eat malicious trespassers—chowing down
on its victims slowly sometimes with
the giant mouth in the center of its stomach.
The moral of all these tales? Don’t be greedy
with natural resources–and always keep your eyes
peeled in the forest or a monster will GET YOU.